BOBBY: This is a '67 XKE.
Oh.
I haven't seen that
car with the cover off--
I can't even tell you how long.
That was my dad's baby.
There you go.
Yeah.
So did he find this locally?
BOBBY: I have no idea
where this came from.
MIKE: [whistles] The Godfather
of European auto design, Enzo
Ferrari, proclaimed
the Jaguar XKE the most
beautiful car he had ever seen.
They were a huge influence
in the sports car world--
design, performance.
I mean, when you see one
coming down the road,
you stand at attention.
There's a guy I
know in Tennessee--
he does Jags.
He works on them, he
buys and sells them.
I'd love to send him some
pictures of this, just so you
can have a jumping off point
and so can we in regards
to the value of it, you know?
I know enough about Jaguars to
know that it's a numbers game.
And what I mean by that is
it's a serial numbers game.
There it is.
I'm going to call my buddy Mike
Mefford in Columbia, Tennessee.
He knows these cars
inside and out.
And I'm going to find out
where those numbers are.
Mike.
MIKE MEFFORD (ON PHONE):
Hey, what's going on, Mike?
I'm looking at a 1967
XKE convertible Jaguar.
I know that the serial
numbers make a big difference.
So where can I see
those at on it?
Yeah.
Well, it's going to
be a really hard part
to get into on this side,
because the car is cranked
up against a bunch of stuff.
Why don't I just send you
some general photographs
of the car so you can
get an idea of just
the overall broad stroke of it?
BOBBY: I remember
playing in that Jaguar
when I was a little kid, hopping
up and down in the front seat,
pretending I was
driving and shifting,
while my dad was working on the
bikes right next to that car.
This was my dad's baby.
And he used to make
jokes with his friends
and say I was waiting
for him to die
to get the car,
which was totally
farthest from the truth.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And then right before
he died, he pulled
it out and had it running.
I was walking around
the passenger side,
and he said to me,
what are you doing?
Where are you going?
And I remember,
my heart stopped.
And I was like, what?
And he's like, you're driving.
Get in.
And it's just like he wanted
me to drive the car with him
still alive.
So I guess that was a big
moment for the two of us.
I finally got to drive it.
- Sure.
The connection
between father and son
can happen a lot
of different ways.
Bobby and his father
had a moment in this car
that Bobby will remember
the rest of his life.
MIKE MEFFORD (ON PHONE): Hello?
MIKE: Hey, Mike, it looks
like it starts with 7R280.
OK.
What year is that?
What kind of value would you put
on the car in this condition?
$45,000 to $55,000.
That's a little better number
than the last you heard.
Yeah.
MIKE: OK.
Jaguar enthusiasts are
all about originality.
It's got to be the original
tranny, the original motor,
the original everything.
Once it's been altered,
that takes it down.
So this is just
going to be a driver.
What would the car be
worth in this condition
if it did have matching numbers?
OK.
What if it was done?
What if the car was done
rolling down the road
and it had matching numbers?
All right.
Well, hey, I very
much appreciate
all of your knowledge.
And as always,
thank you so much.
MIKE MEFFORD (ON PHONE): Bye.
I was thinking of a $30,000
price range on that car.
To find out that it's worth
more than that, it's nice.
MIKE: Well, I'm
glad that we were
able to get a hold of Mike.
- Yeah.
Thanks for helping me get--
He's got a lot
of knowledge, man.
The guy's been in
it a long time.
Bobby is smart enough
and passionate enough
to understand that he
can't do this car justice.
This car needs so much
work, expensive work.
And it needs to be
back out on the road.
Actually, you know what?
I'll give you Mike's
number before I leave.
He could sell it for you.
Let him try to get
your top dollar.
- Cool.
- At $45,000, I'm not a player.
And I want to see him get as
much as he can for the car,
because he deserves it,
his father deserves it.
And what a hell of
a ride they had.